really there's a riveting journey an
emotional
you know I started at Santa Monica just
before the development of this game and
at the time I was working on God or
extension in a similar role and probably
about six months in they did a
presentation where he basically shared
his vision he was just so passionate he
had this like very clear idea of a
father and a son on an incredible
journey changing the character changing
the game still making feel like out of
war and now coming five years later the
journey to get here feels as long as the
journey that they're going on and I
couldn't be more excited
mainline true the game about twenty five
to thirty five hours we've said that and
we stand by that there's there's a lot
to see it's easily the the longest and
and largest got organza date I
think the the three key touch stones are
with combat narrative and exploration
those all weave their way into how
important we have fundamentally changed
the game and those three pillars are
what's going to carry gotta war into the
future the new camera the relationship
with his father in the Sun continuing to
open up and explore and dive deeper into
this Norse universe
the journey that they're on right now is
a catalyst for what's going to bring
them together they are going to learn so
much about each other that by the end of
the game I think they will really feel
like a truly bonded father and son
betrayus into this game was really
probably the biggest signifier that we
are taking Kratos somewhere knew that
we're giving him more dimensionality
Kratos needs a reason to still be on
this planet he needs a reason to go on a
journey he needs new purpose and that's
who at Reyes is at Reyes is the reason
that Kratos is continuing to wake up
every day and move on to the next one
and get to the highest peak Petraeus's
other primary role is being his ally his
support weapon it is
incredibly deliberate that Petraeus is
not just an escort mission he's capable
he's upgradable he is strategic so it
was critical to us at Santa Monica that
we continued to create a strong
single-player game but that we gave
Kratos new purpose in combat and story
boy
one
changing the camera
just brings a fundamentally different
emotional feeling to this game so it all
got a wargames you're looking at it from
almost a Skye point of view and you
don't really feel brought into the world
you don't feel as connected to the
action the camera now being unhinged
over your shoulder when a jogger is
racing at you and you're getting ready
to throw that axe at his head you feel
like the the momentum and the intensity
of that and that's only an over shoulder
camera view
hugely important the team spent a ton of
time creating this world based on
Norse history Norse mythology and even
some inspiration from 80s fantasy films
like the neverending story those three
pillars together kind of created this
term that the art environment team
called mythical realism and I think when
you play this game it feels like a world
that you could actually go to there are
so many different secrets and things to
discover in the game it really adds a
whole new layer to a guy or game that's
never been seen before
there's definitely magic in the game so
as you progress in the game you will
unlock more runic abilities so Kratos
has these two gems gem slots on the axe
and you can mix and match this to unlock
elemental abilities like I slam all
those things bring magic into the game
at Reyes as arrows are imbued with
electricity
later down the road
so magic is as a big part of the game
Pascal wargames have been kind of a
one-way street in your combat and and
kind of the way you can choose the bike
now with more RPG like elements you have
armor you have your axe you have
different latest upgrade each of those
whether in their abilities or giving
them new elemental effects and I think
for the team it just again it just came
back down to let's give the player more
strategic choice how they want to play
this game
be careful now I
think we just want to continue to tell
god of war fans that he may look like a
different Kratos he may have a different
weapon he may have a son the camera
might be unhinged but the moment you
pick up and play this in the first 10
minutes or the first time you encounter
the joggers
it's gonna feel like they got a war game
this game feels as much like I got a war
game as any past and it feels like a
natural next step I think we are eager
to see fans response and we are very
confident that fans